(bright thoughtful music)
(scenes scratching)
- Okay, greetings
everybody, happy Tuesday.
This is a lecture that I
was not expecting to give.
This was going to be Paul
Bushkovitch's guest lecture,
but as you see, I'm gonna give it.
It's about the origins
of the Muscovite state
and Muscovite power.
The way things are are gonna
work the rest of the week,
is that on Thursday, my friend
and colleague Glenn Dynner
is going to give the
lecture on Jews in Ukraine,
something which he is
eminently qualified to do.
Same reading, same
everything, there will just be
a slightly different
person wearing the shirt
with the buttons in front of
the classroom on Thursday.
So please give Professor Dynner
the attention he deserves
for making the schlep up
here and giving the lecture.
One of the TFs will introduce,
and I'll see you again on Tuesday.
So this is also not a lecture
I was expecting to give,
in the sense that when
I gave my first lecture
about the rise of Muscovite power,
I wouldn't have expected
to be in a situation
where there is so much to explain.
So we're in the middle of this war where,
just to take two very obvious
points that are pertinent,
the justification for the war,
or one of the justifications for the war
has to do with the continuation
of some kind of permanent
identity from Kyiv
a thousand years ago into Russia today.
Another point, which you'll
see the pertinence of, I hope,
is that many of the people
who are doing the fighting
in the Russian army today are Asians,
are indigenous people from deep into Asia,
who are disproportionately fighting
and killing and dying in Ukraine.
And so you might be asking yourself,
if you're paying attention
day by day in this war,
"Who are these Buryats,
and why are these Buryats
doing so much fighting
and dying in Ukraine?"
Where do they come into the Russian state?
Why is it that a people
of whom there are only
a few hundred thousand who live somewhere
around Lake Baikal deep
into Asia and are Buddhists,
why are they doing so much
of the fighting and dying in Ukraine?
Why is it that when I visit a woman
living in the suburbs of
Chernihiv, and I'm asking
who the Russian soldiers are
who were in her basement,
she says, "Well actually,
two of them are Buryats."
How is that, who are these people?
What do they have to do
with the history of Russia?
By the end of this lecture, I
hope that all becomes clear.
So I wanna start with a
philosophical reflection
about how you get something from nothing,
because once again in this lecture
we are dealing with the
origins of something.
And of course, the origins of something
is a very tender, sensitive subject.
Origins are always tricky,
because it would be nice
if we could have something from nothing.
You might have noticed that
a lot of origin stories
involve how something, there was something
beautiful and pure at
the beginning, right?
And it was corrupted later on.
There was this little thing
called the Book of Genesis,
which is a bit like that.
You might have noticed
that national stories
are also a bit like that.
There was an ethnicity, it
was pure, it was simple.
It might have been corrupted
later by foreigners,
and bad things happened.
But deep down in the beginning,
it was all folk songs and harmony
before the other people came
and messed everything up.
Naturally, you'll have understood,
I'm sure you're understood already,
but it's been a main theme of this class,
that things don't come out of nowhere.
That the states and the nations
that we're trying to explain
always have something to do with contacts
with other states and nations.
There's always something out there,
which is at the beginning of the story,
but it's not in the
beginning of its own story.
It's in the middle or or at the end.
So one way to deal with this problem
of how you have things
that didn't exist before
is to imagine this, you
know, this state of Eden,
this state of innocence.
Another way to deal with this problem
is the way that social
sciences deal with it,
or the way that, ooh, the
social science PhD perks up.
The way that, that would be
Daniel, yeah he's a postdoc.
Daniel say hi, he's also Ukrainian.
Now you've been doxxed.
So the way that social sciences
generally deal with the question
of how you get something from nothing,
is you just start with the something.
You don't worry about the origins,
things just are as they are.
And something similar can
be said about philosophy,
that we just assume that there's a person,
there's a kind of, you know,
there's a person, the
person is fully formed.
We don't worry about the
way the person came from.
In history, we have to confront,
like the weird stories of origins,
but we also have to come up with
a plausible story of origin ourself.
And I wanted to suggest that a root
for plausible stories of
origin would be something
more like Ovid's "Metamorphoses",
which I don't know if you've studied,
but the "Metamorphoses" of Ovid
are all about weird contacts
involving violence and sex and families
that generally don't work out,
but the theme is transformation.
You're not getting something from nothing.
You're getting something
from something else.
from some kind of encounter.
And history is more like that.
It's, unexpected things arise
from the encounters of things,
and then later on you tell a story
about how it had to be that way.
But at the time, it's all
very messy and confusing.
It involves some kind of transformation.
Okay, check out this segue.
So Ovid's "Metamorphoses" were
probably the major influence
or a major influence on Shakespeare.
When I talked to Zelenskyy
a couple of Saturdays ago in Kyiv,
he made the point that
everything was in Shakespeare,
which has me thinking about
"Hamlet" as I often do anyway.
Hamlet was a prince of what? Help me out.
- Denmark?
- Denmark.
- A hundred out of a hundred
for the classroom, excellent.
Everybody who spoke up got it right,
and everybody who didn't know was quiet,
which is like perfect
yell behavior, well done.
(students laughing)
So Denmark, and Denmark
is an heir of what?
What kind of a state is it?
Vikings, right?
Okay, you fell back on the TFs.
It's a Viking state, right?
So, Denmark, Sweden, Norway,
which for a long time is part of Denmark,
Iceland, and Rus, these
are all Viking states.
These are all post Viking states,
and also another post Viking
state which we might forget,
because we think of it
as so big and important.
It's the language I'm speaking.
- England.
- England, right?
England is also a post Viking state.
So this phenomenon of post Viking states
is very important in European history,
From England all the way
to the East Slavic lands
The England of Shakespeare is
a post Viking state, right?
The Normans, I'm just gonna
run this through with you
and you'll see where it's going.
The Normans who invaded England in 1066,
Norman means Northman or Norseman.
The Normans were a synthetic people
of Vikings who had arrived
in northern France,
who were there for a while,
and then they later invaded England.
When they invaded England in 1066,
they invaded England in
1066 three days after
the Norwegians invaded England in 1066.
It was actually a kind of
post Viking pincer movement
in England in the early autumn of 1066.
The king of Norway who invaded England
in September of 1066 was Harald Hardrada,
who you were definitely going to remember,
was in the service of Yaroslav the Wise
in early Kyivan Rus'.
Harald is the same figure
who shows up in Kyiv,
who doesn't have much else to do,
and becomes a warrior in the
service of Yaroslav the Wise,
who we know about all this
thanks to the Icelandic sagas.
You'll remember Yaroslav the
Wise is the one who shows up
in the Iceland sagas as Jarislief,
less flatteringly as
Jarislief the Lame, right?
So this is all one world, right?
The post Viking, who is invading England
as the Norwegian king, is
the same post Viking Harald
who was in the service of
Yaroslav the Wise in Kyiv,
and who then went on to
serve in Byzantium, okay.
So he fails, by the way.
So Harald has this great, he
has this fascinating life.
He starts out in Norway, he goes to Kyiv,
he serves Yaroslav the Wise.
Shows up in the Icelandic sagas,
which let's face it, none of
us is ever gonna do, right?
Shows up in the Icelandic sagas.
He goes on to Byzantium, he
serves as part of a Ruthenian
or a Rusyn bodyguard in Byzantium,
then goes back to Norway,
succeeds in becoming
King, invades England,
but gets killed right away, okay.
So like that's, you know,
not the way it would've
ended in the Netflix serial,
but that's so, but his
life, this life of Harald,
it reminds us that there's this whole arc
from Scandinavia to Byzantium.
And in this arc of history, right?
Or really from England to Byzantium,
where the Vikings are in the middle,
and the big pushing forces
were the Franks and the Byzantines.
The Franks and the Byzantines are pushing
from one side and the other,
the Vikings show up in the middle,
and then the Vikings end up having to do
with the creation of a
whole bunch of states
from England all the way down,
all the way down to Rus', okay.
So when the Normans,
the Normans are the post
Vikings who win, right?
The Norwegians lose, but the
Normans are the ones who win.
And it's often forgotten
that there were two attacks
on England at exactly the same time,
although I saw some nodding
in the gallery, which is cool.
So the Normans are the post
Vikings who win England.
Their leader goes under the
name of William the Conqueror.
He kills the English king,
he establish his own elites,
and the language has changed, right?
The language has changed.
So remember, another
big theme of this class,
our big argument is how the
language is there for you.
The language and the people
are not necessarily identical.
Languages change, people
move into languages.
So the English language
that we're moving into now,
or that we're using
now has something to do
with William the Conqueror
conquering England.
It would be very hard for me
to create a sentence in English
which doesn't involve a
word which came from French.
You know, I'm not gonna
like show off at this point,
but I will give you,
I'll read you a passage
which we've already read,
which is Chaucer's
"Canterbury Tales" from 1380,
the same passage.
"A knight there was and that a worthy man,
that from the time that he
first began to riden out,
he loved chivalry, truth and
honor, freedom and courtesy."
Right, there isn't gonna
be chivalry or courtesy
in Chaucer without the Normans,
without the post Vikings invading England.
Or Shakespeare and "Hamlet",
the most famous speech
is "to be or not to be" right?
Which includes a beautiful line about how
"conscience makes cowards of us all",
which he couldn't have written
without the word conscience,
which of course is a French word, okay.
So you've gotten the point about this,
this big political cultural synthesis,
which takes place over a few centuries,
and how our world is part of that world.
Our East Slavic Rus' world
is part of that world,
although it's special.
And one way that it's
special, as you know,
is that the East Slavic world Rus'
becomes Christian under the Byzantines,
whereas all the rest of it's going to be
Western Christian, right? Boring.
Whereas our part is going
to be Eastern Christian.
The other thing which is special,
by the time we get to this lecture,
and this is the subject of this lecture,
is that it no longer exists.
So, England, Norway, Norway
slash Denmark, Sweden,
these are all fairly
durable political entities.
England is still around.
I mean, by the end of
the semester let's see
but England is still around,
and Denmark, Norway,
Sweden, they're also around.
Rus' is not still around, and
so that's another difference,
and that's the subject that
we're getting to today.
What actually happens to Rus',
and how are we best to think about that?
So I introduced a next moment of contact
in the last lecture.
The moment of contact I tried to introduce
in the last lecture was
another East/West moment,
which was the Mongols
coming from one side,
and the Teutonic Knights
coming from the other side.
So if we're going to explain
the origins of Lithuania
as we tried to do in the last lecture,
we explain the origins of Lithuania
not by saying they were
always Lithuanians,
they were always wonderful
pagans, they were very innocent.
You know, they did a
lot of human sacrifice,
which is how you preserve
innocence, as we all know.
No I mean honestly, you've had,
I mean the human sacrifice,
well I mean. (sighing)
Where do I draw all the lines on the jokes
knowing that I'm filmed?
(students laughing)
That's just occurred to
me for the first time.
But let's face it, human sacrifice has
a kind of simplicity and clarity,
which other forms of,
you know, ritual don't.
So the, where was I?
Oh, so the Lithuanians, it's
not that the Lithuanians
were always there and they were pure
and they were an ethnicity and so on.
That's not the story at all, right?
The story is that the Lithuanians saw
what happened to the Prussians,
the Lithuanians gathered
together some tribes,
some Pagan tribes who speak
the Baltic Lithuanian language.
The Lithuanians went south and gathered up
most of the lands that had
been Rus', and on that basis
were able to stand up
to the Teutonic Knights.
And then because there was a
rising state called Poland,
the Lithuanians married
into the Polish crown,
and in alliance with
Poland, and having annexed
most of what was Rus', Lithuania had,
there the Lithuanian
rulers created the state
which could actually defeat
the Teutonic Knights.
But all of that only makes
sense, that whole rise
of Lithuania as a great
state only makes sense
if you understand Teutonic
Knights pushing from the West,
Mongols have come in from
the East and destroyed Rus'.
If the Mongols don't destroy Rus',
Lithuania is not going to annex it.
If Teutonic Knights are not pushing in
with their program of
forced Christianization,
the Lithuanians aren't
going to consolidate.
So this is another one of these symphonies
where larger pressures
push, particularities arise,
new states are consolidated, right?
And so we get to this, we've
already gotten to this.
It's the next few verses
in Chaucer, right?
So the Chaucer, "Above all
nations in Pruce and Lettow,
had he reysed and in Ruce,"
you know what that means.
The Teutonic Knights were
the (speaking in German).
Great German word, by the way.
A (speaking in German) now is just like,
"I'm gonna make, you know,
making a little trip,
(speaking in German)."
But in this context, it
means part of a crusade.
You're joining a crusade.
You're coming from France or
England or somewhere far away,
you're going to join in a crusade.
Pruce is Prussia, which
has been fully destroyed.
Lettow is Lithuania, and
Ruce is of course Rus'.
So that's kind of interesting, isn't it?
I'm sure when you read
this in high school,
or in your free time, or when
you read it in the future,
you just skimmed right over,
"What is this Ruce place, R-U-C-E?
Probably Chaucer made it up
to rhyme with Pruce," right?
But no, Ruce is actually
the country R-U-S,
which we've been studying,
which in the 14th century
was a completely unproblematic word, okay.
So this Lithuanian trajectory we followed,
and we're gonna keep following it.
We're gonna keep following
the trajectory of what
in this lecture I'm gonna
call Lithuanian Rus'.
Because if we're gonna understand the,
if we're gonna move east and
understand the consequences
of the Mongol destruction
of Kyiv in 1237 to 1240,
we have to then move into the question
of the successors of Rus'.
And the successors of Rus'
are going to overlap with other things.
They're going to overlap
with the Mongol world,
but not only.
Very briefly, we've already done
one of the successors of Rus'.
One of the successors
of Rus' is Lithuania.
The Lithuanian Grand
Dukes called themselves
the rulers of Ruthenia,
and Ruthenia in Latin,
of Rus' in their own language.
So one of the successors of
of Rus' is Lithuanian Rus'.
A second successor of Rus',
which we briefly talked about,
is Galicia and Volhynia.
So this is all, right?
This is all on your sheet.
Okay? You nodding, thank you.
So Galicia and Volhynia are the two
Westernmost districts of Rus'.
These are very important places to know.
They're very interesting places.
Galicia and Volhynia are English words
which come from Latin,
but the original terms
come from the old Ruthenian
names for the places,
(speaking in foreign
language), hence Galicia,
And then Volhynia in Latin is
actually (speaking in Latin),
but (speaking in Latin),
you don't have to know this,
I'm just giving you a little break.
You don't have to write it
down, I'm just cruising.
So Volhynia in Latin is (speaking Latin),
is from the city of Volodymyr.
Volodymyr becomes (speaking in Latin),
and Volodymyr is course
of city named after
the first baptized ruler of
Russia, which is Volodymyr.
So Galicia and Volhynia are what we call
these Western districts,
they're very important
because they hold out as rulers of Rus'
for an extra century or so.
They, the leaders of Galicia and Volhynia,
claimed also to be the rulers of Kyiv.
They very often actually had
their person ruling Kyiv.
After the Mongol onslaught,
they managed to hold their own
in Galicia and Volhynia.
After 1240 they were
the only princes of Rus'
who actually engaged the
Mongols on the battlefield
with anything other than complete failure.
So, and they managed to hold
Kyiv, actually, but of course.
But they managed to hold their own lands,
and consolidate the rule over
their own lands in the 1240s.
After the end of Kyiv, after
the destruction of Kyiv,
they refer to themselves
as Princes of Rus'
and Princes of all of Rus'.
In case I don't get to it
later, this is a theme.
If you're gonna call
yourself the Prince of Rus',
just go ahead and call yourself
the Prince of all of Rus',
and you will eventually
figure out in practice
how much all of Rus' turns out to be.
That is the answer to the
question of what all of Rus' is.
All of these people called themselves
the Prince of all of Rus', okay?
Nobody said, "I'm the
Prince of Some of Rus',
and maybe somebody else is," no.
They all when they, as
soon as they thought of it,
they all said, "I'm the
Prince of all of Rus'."
And the question of what all of Rus' is,
is determined by practice,
how far you can actually get,
and then you will call that Rus',
whether it was historically Rus' or not.
So in 2022 we're in a war where
Russia is fighting Ukraine
in territories on the basis of the idea
that these territories are
formerly Rus', but they're not.
The lands in the south of Ukraine
are territories of the Crimean Khanate.
They were never part
of Rus', and but never,
so, and this is a traditional theme.
When Moscow, and I'm gonna get to this,
when Moscow takes over Novgorod,
Novgorod suddenly becomes Rus',
but Novgorod didn't itself
think that it was Rus'.
It only becomes Rus'
after it was conquered,
and so on and so forth.
So the whole idea of
controlling all of Rus'
is essentially a pragmatic idea, right?
After the destruction of Rus', okay.
So the point about Galicia-Volhynia
is that it's gonna have a bright future.
Galicia and Volhynia are
very important to the future,
to the history of Ukraine.
But also they maintained some kind
of Rusyn Ruthenian statehood for,
basically a bonus century
into the 1320s, 1330s,
when they fall to Lithuania and to Poland.
So about 1320, the Lithuanians
have gotten to Kyiv,
and Volhynia becomes
part of Lithuania, okay?
Volhynia becomes part of Lithuania.
Galicia, Halychyna, becomes
part of Poland as of as of 1339.
Okay, so that's, so now we
have two successors of Rus'.
We have the Lithuanian Rus',
and we have the Galicia and
Volhynia Rus', that's two.
The third one, the one that we're gonna
focus on today is Mongol Rus'.
So the part of Rus' which falls
durably under Mongol control
from circa 1240 deep
into the 15th century.
So a different story, a
story of multiple centuries,
multiple generations.
Time matters a lot.
So this is just a basic historian's point.
It matters a lot whether
regime governs a territory
for 50 years, a hundred
years, or 300 years, right?
That's just a very,
it's a very basic point.
And so when we're starting to think about
what's different between Galicia-Volhynia
and the Northeastern territories
that become Mongol Rus',
durability of Mongol rule.
Galicia-Volhynia encountered the Mongols.
They only very briefly paid tribute.
The territories of Mongol Rus',
hint, Mongol Rus' is
what's gonna become Moscow
and the Russian Empire and
all the rest of it, okay?
So the territories that
become Mongol Rus',
that are Mongol Rus',
are under Mongol control for centuries.
That's a basic fundamental difference.
So Mongol Rus', here's
another way to think about it.
It is one of the successors
of Rus' for sure,
and we're gonna see the connections
between Mongol Rus' and Kyivan Rus'.
But it is also one of the many
Mongol or post Mongol states
all across Asia and eastern Europe.
So the Mongols, after
they come and destroy,
which admittedly is like,
that's their famous moment.
1240, 1241, they arrive, they destroy,
they conquer everyone.
They have to go back for
a funeral, as happens,
changes all of history, right?
The Batu Khan arrives, he
destroys, no one can resist him.
Gets a phone call,
didn't get a phone call.
He gets notice that he
has to go back to Mongolia
basically, for what?
For a succession crisis.
A funeral is the polite way of saying it,
but a succession struggle.
When someone dies, there's a
succession struggle, right?
Those of you who have families
that don't write wills,
you know what I'm talking about.
So the, uneasy class-based laughter, okay?
(students laughing)
So I have to say that because
apparently they can't hear
when you laugh on the video.
That's been reported to me,
like they can hear the jokes
but like, then there's silence.
(students laughing)
Which from my point of view is
a little bit awkward, right?
It's like, "He's telling
jokes all semester,
and the Yale students are
just a looking at him."
Okay, so 1240, so 1237 to 1241,
that's the period that you all remember.
The Batu Khan comes, he
conquers, no one's resistant,
so he goes back.
But after this, there is the Mongol state,
which is remembered under the name
of the Golden Horde, okay?
And then, but the Golden Horde over time,
itself falls apart into various entities.
And these entities don't,
they're often very fuzzy
in European history.
They kind of just show up on the margins
every now and again, making attacks,
or as allies in wars or whatever.
But these are fairly durable entities.
And we have to understand Moscow
and not just as a post Rus' entity,
but also as one of these
post Mongol entities,
along with the Nogai Horde,
along with the Kazan Khanate,
along with the Crimean Khanate.
And by the way, for
us, the Crimean Khanate
is the most important
because the Crimean Khanate
is the one that controls Crimea,
and then much of the north
coast of the Black Sea,
what's now the south of Ukraine.
So we have to imagine the
Mongols establishing a state,
which over time fragments into a number
of different entities,
of which one is Moscow.
Of which one is Moscow.
Now, how is Moscow different?
Moscow is different in religion.
It's not Pagan as the Mongols are,
to use the term of abuse
that the Christians use.
And Moscow doesn't convert to Islam.
This is important too.
The rest of these
entities convert to Islam.
So, but Moscow doesn't,
Moscow is Orthodox.
Moscow's Orthodox, but it's Orthodox
in an interesting way, right?
It's Orthodox in a place,
mark this for the future.
It's Orthodox in a place
where there's no other
way of being Christian.
This is really important, I mean,
I think right down to the present moment.
There's no other way of being Christian.
If you're Christian,
you're Orthodox, that's it.
Whereas west of this, in Kyiv
and in the rest of Europe,
there are going to be lots of
other ways of being Christian.
And even if you are Orthodox,
in what's now Ukraine,
Belarus, Poland, Lithuania,
you're going to be in
a series of encounters
with other sorts of Christians
over the next few centuries.
In Moscow, this is not true.
Orthodoxy is Christianity,
Christianity is Orthodoxy.
And this is all, and related
to this, also to mark,
there isn't any theology.
There isn't any disputation
about religion in Moscow.
In points further west
there is going to be,
the Orthodox are going to take part
in all of the interesting conversations
around Reformation,
Counter-Reformation, all of that.
That's not going to be happening
in Moscow until much later,
when Moscow and Kyiv come into
contact for the first time,
which is not for centuries.
It's not for centuries,
it's not in this lecture,
it's in the 17th century, okay.
So we're in Mongol Rus'.
Mongol Rus' is the northeast.
It's the district which I
mentioned last time, Suzdal.
And then Suzdal, surrounding territories,
the northeast of what had been Rus'.
And the way that the political
system is set up by this,
is set up in this Northeastern
Rus', this Mongol Rus',
is really a kind of fresh start,
in the sense that the Mongols
have come and destroyed.
Okay, good, that's true for everyone.
Then there's the Black
Death, it's a bit of a mess.
There's really no one around to write.
And in addition to that, a new principle
of political succession is set up.
The principle of political
succession in the old Rus',
the one based in Kyiv
was admittedly very messy
and to the point of incomprehensibility,
but it had something to do
with the ruler and his sons.
That's about as much as we can say.
And that's by the way,
not so unusual in Europe.
This whole idea that
it was the eldest son,
and it was all very simple.
That usually covers over a whole bunch
of illegitimacy and
bloodshed, but you know, okay.
So illegitimacy and
bloodshed gets a lot of nods.
I just wanna record that for the camera.
All right, so focus.
So in Northeastern Rus',
in and around Suzdal,
there's a new succession
principle which is,
how well can you collect
taxes for the Mongol overlord?
That's the new principle of power.
So the Mongols accept that
there's something called Rus'.
They have no trouble with that,
but who is the Grand Prince of Rus'?
The Grand Prince of Rus' is
the person who can collect the tribute.
So that is a new principle of rule.
That is new compared to Kyiv obviously,
where if you were in Kyiv,
you were the one taking
the tribute, right?
And by the way, this is a
really fundamental thing
about political power.
If you want to figure out
who is actually in charge,
who is paying tribute to whom?
Because everyone says,
"I'm the king and the tsar,
and all the galaxies," and so on, right?
That's very easy.
Having stationary, okay, they
didn't have stationary yet,
but having a list of
titles is very easy, right?
But what really matters is,
are you paying the tribute,
or is someone paying the tribute to you?
So the rulers of Muscovy
had titles, right?
They were the Grand Princes of Moscow,
which sounds great and
certainly had its pluses.
But they were paying
tribute to the Mongols,
and they were the Grand Princes of Moscow
because they could pay
tribute to the Mongols.
The Mongols chose the man who
could collect the tribute.
And so that's a different
principle of succession.
The people who ran Mongol
Rus' were princes of,
they were princes who were
descended from the old Rus'.
Not in any particular distinction,
but they were of the blood,
but they were only the
Grand Princes of Rus'
because they were the ones
who could collect the taxes.
And then the other way
that this is a fresh start
is that the whole system
is based in a new city,
which is Moscow.
So Moscow existed as some
kind of fort or something
in the 12th century, but
Moscow had no princely line.
Moscow is not a district in old Rus'.
Nobody goes to Moscow
to rule anything, right?
It's not one of these districts
Suzdal or like Chernihiv,
where you go and you rule.
It's not a district at all.
It's no place, it's nowhere.
Moscow becomes a town,
becomes a meaningful place
with a princely line after the
Mongol destruction of Kyiv,
and because it's a Prince of Moscow
who's able to collect the tribute.
It was also, well, there's
also some marriage involved.
In 1317, Yuri, who was a Prince of Moscow,
married the sister of the Khan
of the Golden Horde, right?
As one does, you know, in
situations like this, right?
So he also marries into
power, and at that point,
power passed durably from a more important
bigger city called Tver to Moscow.
And from that point, Moscow is gonna be
the center of this entity.
And it's gonna be the Princes of Moscow
who eventually remember,
it takes them a while,
but who eventually remember to say,
"We are the rulers of all of Rus'."
The first one, by the way
to, as far as we know,
who says that he's the ruler of all Rus'
was Vasily I, who ruled from 1389 to 1399.
And the evidence we have is there's a coin
where he appears, and he says,
"I am the ruler of all Rus'."
On the other side of that coin, it says,
"Long live Sultan Tokhtamysh",
which reminds you of what the
actual political order is.
He's the ruler of all of Rus', terrific.
But what he means by all
of Rus' is the bit of Rus'
that is under the control
of the Golden Horde, right?
That's under the control of the Mongols.
Now all of this, the Mongol
connection is very important
because when the Mongol
connection is broken,
the basic state form remains.
There's no clear moment
in the history of Muscovy
where you can say, "Okay,
the Mongols were here,
they were doing everything,
and then they got on their
little horses and left."
That's not how it worked at all.
The way that it worked was that
somewhere in the middle
of the 15th century,
Moscow stops paying tribute.
But they don't change at that point,
they just stop paying tribute.
It's the same entity, okay?
So have a state which is
in some way post Rus'.
Religion, princely family,
language, all of that.
But it's also in many ways a new start,
a new start under the Mongols.
So it's post post Rus', I would
say, and it's post Mongol.
Let me say a word now about the system,
because the system is
incredibly interesting.
First of all, and to give
credit where credit is due,
the Muscovites knew how to fight.
And the reason they knew how to fight
was that they fought with,
and then eventually against the Mongols.
So the Mongol cavalry techniques,
which the Mongols brought
with them to Europe
and which no one could withstand,
were then learned by the
Muscovites, because of course,
the Muscovites were
part of the same state.
They were fighting on the same side.
So they were very good at war.
And the way that they set up
their armies in five parts
has everything to do with the way
that the Mongols set set up their armies.
So that's very important to know.
The Muscovites knew how to fight,
that is part of their heritage.
The heritage that they don't have is all
the legal bureaucratic heritage of Kyiv,
which we've talked about earlier.
They're free and clear of that.
For better or worse, they're
free and clear of that.
It's rather the Lithuanians
who pick up that heritage,
which means that the legal tradition
in Mongol Rus' is very simple.
It starts from the idea that
the tsar owns everything,
which is convenient.
I mean, it's very convenient
if you're the tsar.
And okay, and when I say all this,
don't overdo it, but do
record this and think about it
when you're thinking about
the history of Russia,
the centuries, as centuries pass.
So all the property belongs
to the tsar, the ruler.
You can't really own land.
You can own land conditionally.
If I'm the tsar, I'm gonna be the tsar,
'cause I'm the one who's talking.
You can own land conditionally
until I say that you don't anymore, right?
So land ownership can
be broken at any time.
You own land practically, in exchange
for service to me, the tsar.
So everyone who owns land by definition
is a servant of the tsar,
and almost always that's military service.
So this is the way the army is set up.
You get to control land, but in return,
you serve in the army.
That is the fundamental deal.
You control land in exchange
for military service,
and I can break that at any point.
So you're the fighting class,
but you're not exactly a nobility
in the sense of West European nobilities.
There is no legal list,
there's no register,
there's no patent of nobility.
There's no beautiful piece of paper
which you can produce and say,
"I have a better Latin script
than you," or whatever.
You're not really nobles in the sense
of being a legal estate.
You're really nobles it more
or less at my at my pleasure.
So there aren't property rights,
and there aren't really
feudal rights either.
There's this deal, which
is a very effective deal.
It works very well, a fighting class
in exchange for control of land.
And of course it works very well,
so long as we're getting
more land all the time.
And that's part of the
magic of the system.
We are going to be getting
more land all the time
for at least a couple of centuries.
The state is going to grow spectacularly,
first west into Europe,
then south into formerly
Muslim territories,
and then west all the
way to the Pacific Ocean
in just a couple of centuries, okay.
This is basically an
agrarian country though.
So part of this system is serfdom.
So you are off fighting wars,
but you have a land manager
and you have serfs on your territory.
The Russian peasants live in communes.
The word for commune, I forgot
to write this down, sorry,
is (speaking in Russian),
which is a very evocative
Russian word, 'cause it
also means world and peace,
which is practically a whole
universe of meaning, right?
So commune, peace and
world, all the same word.
The right that the
peasants had in the system,
The one right, was to leave
and go somewhere else.
So think about how this works.
The peasants are in a commune.
The commune is on the land of someone
who's in this warrior class.
The person who's in the warrior class
is personally dependent upon the tsar.
No way anywhere down in this hierarchy
does anyone really have
any kind of formal rights.
The right that the
peasants have is to leave,
and the story of serfdom is
that that right is taken away.
Beginning from 1497 through
let's say through 1649,
all of these rights are
completely taken away.
So in 1497, I'm not gonna
tell the whole story,
but in 1497, you're right as peasants,
okay, I'll be the peasant.
My right as a peasant to leave
is limited to one day a year.
Okay, that's a restriction.
And then in 1581, that day is taken away,
so it's now zero days.
And then from there, the law
escalates in the sense of,
the landowner has five years
to find you if you run away,
10 years to find you if you run away,
15 years to find you if you run away,
and serfdom is considered
to be complete by 1649,
when the landowner has
your whole life to find you
after you run away, right?
So at that point, there's no, like,
you can't even go
underground for 15 years.
You're a serf until you die.
So roughly 1% of the population
belongs to the service
class, or the fighting class.
Most of the remaining 99% of
the population are peasants,
and most of these peasants
are bound to the land.
So that's a system which has a logic.
It's a system which has a
logic in which you can make,
you will do well if you're
in the fighting class,
if there was more land.
If you were a serf, the only
thing you can think about
is somehow escaping very far away,
and we're gonna get to
that before we're done.
So territorial expansion,
there is a lot of it.
Russia, so Muscovy I should say,
as soon as it comes into being,
it instantly joins the
European age of discovery.
That's one way to think about it, right?
So all these other places,
like the Netherlands,
or Portugal, or Spain,
or the Italian states,
they've been around for a while,
they've been doing other things.
Muscovy comes into being,
and immediately, boom,
it's expanding territorially
on a tremendous scale.
The Muscovy of 1533 is six times as big
as the Muscovy of 1462,
and that's just the start.
So there are three waves of expansion.
The first wave of expansion is
in Europe, and it's westward.
So Moscow is pretty far east, right?
So these places we're
talking about, Moscow, Tver,
that was the extreme northeast of Rus'.
It's very far east from the point of view
of Rus' or from Europe.
The first move that Moscow
makes is to the west,
controlling in the 1470s, 1480s, 1490s,
the other cities that are Orthodox,
not necessarily from Rus',
the other cities that are
Orthodox that are to its West.
The most important of these is Novgorod.
And Novgorod is an ancient city.
Novgorod was a place where
many of the rulers of Rus'
ruled at some point in their careers.
It was comparably important
to Rus' at some points.
It was a very important trading state,
but also it was a city which
was governed by its notables.
It had an assembly, right?
It wasn't a completely
vertical situation at all.
This was true of Novgorod,
this was true of Pskov.
These places, Novgorod, Pskov,
cities where there was freedom,
at least for what we now
call, like the bourgeoisie.
Cities where there was assembly, right?
These cities had bells.
This is a sort of charming, or uncharming,
or depressing detail.
They would ring the bell,
which would mean the assembly should meet.
But then symbolically, when
these cities were sacked
by Moscow and put under Muscovite control,
the bells would then
be ritually taken away.
So in 1510, for example,
the bell from Pskov
was taken down and taken away,
and everyone knew what that meant.
So 1470s, 1480s, 1490s,
early 16th century,
Ryazan falls in 1520.
These are cities that
are similar culturally,
in the sense that they're Orthodox,
but these are not actually
necessarily cities of Rus'.
So just to, I'm banging
this idea across I know,
but Rus' kind of becomes
whatever you can make it be.
People in Novgorod did not
think they were part of Rus'.
But once you conquer it,
it then sort of becomes
part of Rus', because
everything you control,
you're going to call Rus'.
So first chapter of expansion
is westward into these cities,
which were bigger, Novgorod
much bigger than Moscow.
Bigger, more sophisticated,
richer than Moscow.
But once they are defeated by Moscow,
this is very important.
Over time their elites
are humiliated, crushed,
dispersed, brought to
Moscow, made dependent,
and the system that I described
in Moscow is then applied.
It takes generations, but is then applied
in these other cities, so that the people
who had been notables there
become servants of the tsar,
because there is no other status besides
servant of the tsar, which is available.
There is resistance,
there is attempts to get
Lithuania to help, all
kinds of things happen.
But the basic story is
the people who had had
some kind of status of
their own in these cities
no longer have status of
their own under Moscow.
The Moscow system has spread west.
Second stage is territorial
expansion south,
and this mostly takes place under Ivan IV,
who, the one who's known
as Ivan the Terrible,
although his name is really more
like threatening, or something like this.
But Ivan IV, who rules for a
very long time, 1547 to 1584.
Here again, it's remarkable
how just as Moscow
comes into being, it is immediately,
it immediately begins to expand.
So Ivan IV, he defeats the
Khanate of Kazan in 1552,
in the years after that.
Kazan, it's today the third
biggest city, or maybe the,
I think it's the third biggest city
in the Russian Federation
today, maybe the fourth.
Major city, it's the capital
of what's now called Tatarstan.
It's still Muslim, it's
still a Muslim place.
Kazan is where, if you can
remember all the way back
to like a couple weeks ago,
this is where the Bulgars were.
So like the Volga
Bulgars convert to Islam,
they are under the Mongols.
They're known as the Khanate of Kazan.
They are conquered by Moscow in 1552.
And so if you're asking yourself,
"Why are there Tatars in Russia today?
Who are these Tatars?"
This is who the Tatars are.
The Tatars are the people
who were in the Khanate of Kazan,
who were in Volga, Bulgaria.
These are the people who are today
in Russia south of Moscow.
So this defeat has a couple of meanings,
a couple of very important meanings.
The first is Muscovy, you know,
basically not long after
it's come into existence
is already an empire, in the sense
that it is ruling people
of a different religion,
a lot of people of a
different religion, Muslims.
Right away, right?
So not long after Moscow comes
into existence as a state,
it is already ruling
lots and lots of people
of a different religion than itself.
And that is a durable fact about
Moscow, the Russian Empire,
and for that matter, the
Russian Federation today.
The second thing, which is
very important about this,
and I'm gonna return to
it, is that this opens up,
this opens up the Volga River
and the lands east of the Volga River,
which are generally known as Siberia.
So from European Russia all
the way to the Pacific Ocean,
beautiful, rich territory,
lots of valuable things,
furs mainly.
There are only about 200,000 people
living there at the time.
That is now, once the Khanate
of Kazan is destroyed,
that's all open.
The last move of Ivan
though is to go back west
and begin the Livonian wars.
Which don't worry, in two lectures
we're gonna spend a lot of
time on the Livonian wars.
In the Livonian wars, Ivan is trying
to pick up the Baltic territories,
which were originally laid
down by the Teutonic Knights.
The Teutonic Knights
convert to Lutheranism,
they change their ways, they
build nice towns, they trade.
And their realm starts to
fall apart, Moscow intervenes.
Moscow's intervention,
and we're gonna have
much of a lecture about this,
generates a Lithuanian
and a Polish response.
This is the 1560s.
The Lithuanian and Polish response
is to form the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth.
And as we're gonna see,
it's the Polish Lithuanian
Commonwealth which actually
generates the conditions of
the thing that we call Ukraine.
So in a weird way, it
was Ivan the Terrible
who's responsible for Ukraine,
So you know, we've heard
how it was, you know, Lenin,
we've heard how it was Hitler,
we've heard how it was
the gays and the Jews
and the European Union, but you know,
Ivan the Terrible actually
sets off the chain of events.
Okay, don't worry, we'll develop all this.
But the thing to know here in this context
is that the Livonian wars don't go well.
They go very badly, and
Ivan becomes quite paranoid
and carries out a whole series
of seriously weird purges,
to which one could
devote an entire lecture,
which involve a private
guard called the Oprechniki,
who go around with black hoods
and severed dogs heads or
wolf's heads on their horses,
and carry out purges, murderous purges
of the people who are
supposed to be traitors,
a reign of terror all over Muscovy
in the 1560s and into the 1570s.
All these cities, like
Novgorod for example,
are purged again, and in Novogorod
thousands of people are murdered.
This is the part of Ivan's rule,
which is why he's remembered
as Ivan the Terrible.
This, the paranoia, the purges.
And in this situation
where they're losing,
to pull in Lithuania, and there are,
these crazy purges are going on.
The Crimean Khanate, which still exists,
Kazan Khanate gone, Crimean
Khanate still there.
The Crimean Khanate invades and
almost takes Moscow in 1571.
Okay, so at that point
Ivan, by the way, sobers up.
Sobers up, the purges slow down.
I didn't mean that in the alcoholic sense.
He had many, he had many issues.
But no, he seems to take
stock and the purges slow down
and then they make a truce
with Poland and Lithuania in 1582.
But the other thing
that happens under Ivan,
which is what I'm gonna leave you with,
is the third direction of expansion,
which is actually global.
So it's eastern, but it's actually global.
Getting it all the way
to the Pacific Ocean
is actually global.
Getting all the way to the Pacific Ocean,
starting around the same time you begin
trade with England, which was 1554.
That was a total accident, by the way.
The English were in the Arctic Ocean
looking for a passage to China,
which hint, hint, they didn't find.
And all of the boats
capsized except for one,
but the one that didn't found Russia.
And being merchants they said,
"Oh, I bet these guys
have something to trade,"
and of course they did.
And one of the things the
Russians had to trade was fur,
which was a hugely
important good at the time.
And where do you get fur?
You get fur in Siberia.
And so this is actually,
is that me? I'm sorry.
So the global part of this is that Russia
is entering the global
economy on the Atlantic side
and on the Pacific side
at about the same time.
So the way that this works
in practice, very quickly,
is that the territory,
once the Kazan Khanate
has been defeated, this territory is open.
The Muscovites move in.
The people that they
send are called Cossacks,
and a Cossack is basically a free person.
We'll talk more about them.
The Cossacks go and they conquer,
with the help of European weapons.
This is also a globalized element of this,
and it's why Russia is
part of the European
age of discovery, if
you like, at this point.
They're using muskets, they're
using gun powder weapons,
and that's one of the reasons
why they're so successful.
They find lots of people
who they can oppress
and collect tribute from
in the form of beaver
and black fox, and especially sable pelts,
which are enormously
profitable at the time.
They get their way across, they
move across all of Siberia.
Very quickly, the first
expedition to the Pacific
is in 1639.
A man called Semyon Dezhnev
crosses the Bering Strait.
That is, he reaches
North America, in 1647.
So in a very, very short period of time,
a huge amount of territory, right?
An eighth, a ninth of the Earth's surface
is now under control of Moscow.
And that's not just a matter of territory,
it's also a matter of human variety.
There are roughly 500
groups in this territory,
speaking roughly 120 languages.
And many of these groups still exist,
and you can read about them in the news
as they're being mobilized
to fight in Ukraine.
But it's also, as I've tried to stress,
it's globalization,
because Russia is trading
the Atlantic and the
Pacific at the same time.
And finally, this is the very
last sentence, with China.
So one of the limits, one of
the few limits that Russia,
that Moscow reaches is with the Chinese.
They reach, they sign a
peace treaty with China
in 1689 in Nerchinsk, which
establishes the border
between Muscovy and China.
But more importantly, it
establishes terms of trade
between Muscovy and China
so that all those furs
can be traded to China for luxury goods.
So the route to China, which the English
were trying to discover,
eventually does take place,
but by way of land rather
than by way of sea.
So this is the origins of Muscovite power.
A new system, an enormous
amount of new territory,
and the success of
centralization in all of this.
What this has to do with
all of Rus', of course,
you know, is very fuzzy.
If I've gotten anything
across, I hope it's this,
that Rus' has many successors,
and we wouldn't want deny the connection
between Rus' to Galicia-Volhynia,
or to Lithuania,
or at the state that's founded in Moscow.
But Moscow also has very much
to do with the Mongol period,
which lasts for so very much
longer there than elsewhere.
And it has very much to do with the fact
that its first moves when
it comes into existence,
are territorial expansion to
Europe, but mostly into Asia.
Okay, thank you very much.
(bright chiming music)